Film Courage: What is it like as a director
trying to make your day?
By the hour, minute.
Jay Silverman, Photographer/Director/Producer:
Number one, I’m the executive producer of
this movie, I’m also the director and I
think it’s so critical that boundaries are
set right away and in the case of Will Newman
(my producer) he personally was responsible
in advance for scheduling may day in addition
to my DP.
And Matt Edwards who is the DP of the movie
is really the most important person on the
set because if he slows down or can’t make
the day he previously agreed to this has an
incredibly dark story and at the end of the
day the next day you have a whole other and
what Will made such an
asset is your ability to be honest with yourself.
And I mentioned earlier that the screenwriter
had a beautiful third act where hot air balloons
where being chased by a truck and actors were
hanging out of the truck and hanging out of
the balloon and there is just no way we could
have done that in even an economical way versus
the way we ended up doing in which was less
than half of a day on the Rio Grande.
That was our creative solution that the screenwriter
agreed to.
If she didn’t agree to it we would have
come up with something else.
And as a producer and a director it was my
goal to make the goal everyday and I think
we made the day everyday but one day and the
reason we didn’t make it that day was something
that was unexpected happens and it happens
on the time in the business.
I mean one of the real tragedies of doing
independent filmmaking is the things you can’t
control.
So my movie takes place predominantly in Taos,
New Mexico and in LA.
And I made a significantly smart decision
to build a kitchen here on my stage and we
could flick the switch each day and modify
the lighting and never have to worry about
the sun going behind the building next door
and never having to worry about going into
overtime and no light at all.
It gave us the ability to do two times more
work than we would have New Mexico in a real
kitchen.
And most importantly creatively I was able
to work with a set designer I was able to
create something that I felt was the most
magical parts of the movie was her domain,
the restaurant, her dining room.
And all that was made on the stage.